The Saw timeline is really well thought out.
Despite the fact that there are constant flashbacks,
retcons and events being told out of order,
you can still piece together everything in
a way that makes sense.
Except for the history of this guy, Logan
Nelson.
If you want to see how Nelson breaks the timeline,
and my idea of how it can be fixed, then stick
around to the end of this video.
[INTRO]
Hello, and welcome to Horror History.
My name The Professor -- not that Professor
-- Professor CZsWorld and in today’s lesson
I’m talking Saw.
More specifically, the most recent of Jigsaw’s
many disciples, Lieutenant Logan Nelson.
Nelson made his debut in the eighth movie,
Jigsaw, and there are still unanswered questions
about his character that may be left open
for future installments, as hinted at by the
directors, The Spierig Brothers.
I will talk about those possibilities, but
before we can get there, we’ve gotta take
it back to the debut of the first disciple.
Logan Nelson was born on August 18th, 1973.
He grew up to become a medic, and at 6”2’
195 lbs he was also a pretty big force to
be reckoned with.
When Logan was 29, he was doing his residency
in Metropolitan City at The Angel of Mercy
Hospital, the same hospital that Dr. Lawrence
Gordon was treating a patient named John Kramer.
One day in 2003 he was responsible for labeling
a couple of x-rays and accidentally switched
the labels, an event that prevented John’s
doctor from correctly diagnosing his brain
tumor in its early stages.
That small mistake ended up being one of his
biggest mistakes, because it was this that
caused Kramer, who would one day become known
as “The Jigsaw Killer” to include Nelson
in his first ever game, a challenge that included
five contestants fighting for their lives
to prove that they cherish life.
He is put into a room at a secluded barn with
four other wrongdoers, but the sedation used
on Logan doesn’t wear off at the same time
as the others, so by the time he wakes up,
he’s nearly already been pulled into a wall
of spinning saw blades.
He ends up getting cut by the blades, leaving
permanent scars on his back, but luckily,
John realized that he didn’t have a fair
chance, and didn’t want him dying over an
honest mistake, so he ran out to save him
and give him a second chance.
After stitching up his back, he made Nelson
his apprentice, teaching him Jigsaw’s moral
code and engineering techniques.
Together, they built what would become known
as one of Jigsaw’s most iconic traps, the
reverse bear trap, and John would impress
the manta,
“we'll speak for the dead,”
which had a great impact on Nelson going forward.
John’s partnership with Nelson would come
to an end however, later that year when Nelson
shipped out to serve in the military, where
he was a Lieutenant from May 2003 through
July of 2005.
“Logan was our medic in Fallujah.”
Fallujah is short for Al-Fallujah, a city
in Iraq where two of the biggest battles of
America’s Iraq War took place.
Keith Hunt also served in Fallujah, and mentions
that even as a medic, Nelson took out some
Taliban guys before being captured.
He was tortured, possibly with hydrofluoric
acid, which he recognizes the effects of as
a medical examiner years later.
According to Nelson’s file, “he was imprisoned
Republican Guard loyalists for 5 months and
11 days.
During his imprisonment, along with four other
members of his medical patrol, he was subjected
to an array for interrogation methods for
the purpose of discovering his unit’s plans
for the recapture of Fallujah.”
This is almost certainly where he developed
his stone cold demeanor, we see it later when
he’s being questioned by Keith Hunt and
of course at the end where he goes full punishment
mode.
“Lieutenant Nelson was released in a prisoner
exchange brokered by army general Fitzpatrick
in May 2005 at which time he was transferred
to VISN5 (VA Capital Healthcare Network in
Maryland) where he received PTSD treatment
for 23 months.”
In other words, he was still jumping at shadows
after getting free, so they treated him in
a hospital for veterans from May 2005 until
April 2007.
During that time,
“Patient exhibited signs of extreme anxiety
and antisocial behavior for approximately
7 weeks,”
Much like me when I’m editing a video...
“during which Dr. Perry prescribed a regime
of Serotonin Reuptake Inhibitors (or SSRIs)
with limited success.”
We don’t know exactly when Logan met his
wife, but it seems like his daughter was conceived
in December of 2005 while he was still under
treatment.
“Nelson was eventually released under his
own recognizance on August 9th 2006, but suffered
a severe relapse following the birth of his
daughter Melissa.
Lieutenant Nelson lashed out at a neighbor
with a yard sign and was arrested following
an argument with his wife’s physician, in
which Logan repeatedly struck the doctor in
the head and was later sued for injuries.”
Man…
I wonder what the yard sign said.
Go figure.
Nelson considered himself a ‘broken man’
after the war.
“Ten years ago I came out of the war a broken man.”
Yes.
That’s what I just said.
But Jigsaw helped him put the pieces of his
life back together again… like a Jigsaw
puzzle -- see what they did there?
Now this is where the timing of events gets
a little bit wonky, because I don’t really
think Lieutenant Nelson linked up with Jigsaw
again after the war, long story short, because
Jigsaw was pretty busy with some other stuff
at the time and he was dead by the time Nelson
had his big relapse and yard sign incident.
I think what Logan means with that line, is
that it was Jigsaw’s teachings that helped
him eventually overcome the PTSD.
There are some other possibilities, but I’ll
talk about those a little bit later.
“He was readmitted to VISN5 on September
12, 2006 and improved steadily through the
rest of the year.
Nelson was re-released on December 12, 2006
and has since been considered medically clear,
and has not been prescribed SSRIs since May
of 2007.”
He was released from the care of Dr. Angus
Perry on February 10th, 2007, and “his breakdown
of the summer of 2006 is considered an aberration,
and Dr. Perry has signed off on his condition,
insisting that Nelson is not a threat to himself.
He was awarded a purple heart on October 5th,
2007.
So all of this, from 2003-2007, between being
in the war overseas and dealing with his own
mental illness battle back home, helps explain
why he, as one of Jigsaw’s disciples, wasn’t
a factor during the seven Saw films, which
take place from 2004-2007, not including the
flashbacks.
To this point, an argument can be made for
the morality of Nelson’s character, but
what would happen after returning to the Metropolitan
area caused him to take an ever darker outlook
on life.
Logan used his knowledge in the field of health
care to become a medical examiner not long
after the Jigsaw saga had concluded, but despite
Jigsaw leaving a lasting legacy on the city,
criminals eventually started to run rampant
again and bodies continued to pile up.
During his first year in county, the body
of an 8-year old girl showed up on Nelson’s
examination table, an event that he felt could
have been prevented.
It happened one day after Detective Halloran,
who I’m just now realizing I don’t know
the first name of, captured a predator named
Alastor Shultz, and brought him in for questioning,
but during the interrogation got too rough,
resulting in Schultz getting off on a technicality
where he quickly took his anger out on an
innocent young girl.
Logan held this against Halloran for a long
time, which wasn’t helped by the fact that
this was the first of many transgressions
on Halloran’s part.
As innocent bodies continued to pile up on
Nelson’s table… well ok, they didn’t
literally pile up, he looked at them one at
a time probably… but as the body count continued
to grow, so did Nelson’s disgust for Detective
Halloran and his methods.
He also called Halloran an impulsive ***hole
a couple times in the media, which created
a tension between the two that everyone knew
about.
It wasn’t just Halloran’s excessive use
of force that bothered Nelson though, he also
had a penchant for letting criminals off the
hook.
The most notable example was Edgar Munsen,
a meth addict, thief and assaulter who wiggled
out of two arrests because he was Halloran’s
informant.
I’d cite the lack of discipline as a major
reason that Munsen never cleaned up his act
and ended up committing the most heinous crime
of all: putting ketchup on a hot dog.
"The game's just getting started."
Nah, I’m just kidding, he ****ing murdered
Nelson’s wife.
I think it was at this point that Nelson probably
started plotting his revenge.
With Jigsaw’s words, “we speak for the
dead”, still echoing in his head, with his
unique position as the county medical examiner
and with his close proximity to Halloran and
his department, Nelson began paying close
attention to the criminals that Halloran let
off of the hook.
His aim was to recreate the game that Jigsaw
had placed him in all those years ago using
criminals from Halloran’s botched cases
along with Halloran and himself.
Nelson discovered his first candidate in 2011.
A degenerate gambler named Malcolm Neale was
partially responsible for the death of his
wife when the people he owed money to broke
into his home and slit Mrs. Neale’s throat.
Halloran never managed to put him away for
the illegal gambling charges and Neale fit
the profile of one of the guys from Jigsaw’s
original game at the barn, so Nelson took
things into his own hands to punish him.
Over the next five years, he kept his eyes
open and found two other criminals that he
deemed similar to the other two contestants
of John’s game at the barn.
In 2016 he abducted them and put them through
their own game.
As expected, they made the same mistakes as
their predecessors did -- though it’s not
really clear if Nelson made the games winnable
like Jigsaw did, or if he was just torturing
them to avenge the dead.
The game began when Nelson abducted his wife’s
killer, Edgar Munsen and left him in an abandoned
warehouse with an audio tape created by splicing
together old archival audio of John Kramer
to make it look like Jigsaw was back from
the dead and conducting a new game.
Surprisingly, it didn’t end up sounding
like a bad soundboard prank call.
*dial tone*
"Thank you for calling the front desk, this is Jake, how can I help you?"
"Hello. Greetings."
"Oh **** wait,  you're the Saw dude!"
"There's a man in the room with you."
"Who's watching Saw? WTF?"
"Welcome to your rebirth."
"You think it's over just because I'm dead?"
The tape told Munsen he had to get to a certain
rooftop with a trigger that would start the
next game.
He arrived there, chased by police, and each
of them aimed to destroy the trigger not knowing
that Nelson was watching from another rooftop
with a sniper, which he used to shoot Munsen
simultaneously.
After using his inside access to obtain a
capsule of John Kramer’s blood and, he injects
it into Malcolm Neale’s fingernails before
putting the body on display in public for
police to find, and ultimately bring back
to him to examine with his very lovely assistant,
Eleanor Bonneville.
In fact, he wisely allows her to be the one
to notice the Jigsaw piece he had cut out
of the victim’s head.
She doesn’t notice the flash drive lodged
in his face, so Nelson makes sure the police
know about it by bringing it to light himself.
On the outside of it, the text reads: and
then there were four.
The drive contains an audio file, so why don’t
we roll it?
“The games have begun again.
And they will not stop until the sins against
the innocent are atoned for.
I will take care of the next four.
You take care of the rest.”
Just as Jigsaw and his other apprentices did
during the Saw saga, Logan is leaving this
as a message directly for Detective Halloran.
That evening, Nelson would deposit the next
body from his recreated game at the Pig Farm.
This one was supposed to resemble a woman
named Carly from the original game.
He tosses her body from the rooftop of St.
Peter’s hospital, the same hospital where
Edgar Munsen is being treated for his gunshot
wound.
This time the body has a sign that says, “and
then there were three.”
The purpose of counting down like this is
to crank up the pressure on Detective Halloran
and force him to solve the mystery; to find
and put a stop to the game while there are
still living contestants to rescue.
However, it’s all a facade, because the
only two living contestants at this point
are Nelson himself
and Detective Halloran who is being lured
to the game’s location by this lie.
Once again, Nelson is called in to examine
a corpse that he created, this time dropping
more hints by pointing out the victim was
killed by hydrofluoric acid, not a rooftop
fall -- a nice little homage to one of Jigsaw’s
traps in Saw 6 where the same acid is used
in the game where William Easton is executed.
It’s also probably a satisfying act for
Nelson, who was also tortured with HF acid
during his time being imprisoned in the war.
Before the last member of the game is revealed,
something strange comes up with Nelson’s
assistant, Eleanor that completely changes
Logan’s plan.
That night, Logan has to stay late at work,
and video chats his daughter and the babysitter
to say goodnight, highlighting what I think
is a possible weakness for him going forward.
He clearly cares a lot about his daughter.
There’s only one Jigsaw apprentice of the
past who has a kid.
I’ll give you a clue, they used to work
at the same hospital together.
Lawrence Gordon found out how hard it is to
have your child taken hostage as part of Jigsaw’s
game way back in the first movie, but we’ve
also seen similar tactics used to manipulate
characters like Eric Matthews and Jeff Denlon.
After getting off the call, Detectives Halloran
and Hunt confront Nelson and explain that
his hot assistant…
I mean... his assistant... has been sending
a lot of web traffic to a website called Jigsaw
Rules.
And no, I’m not sure if it’s called that
because they’re fans of Jigsaw, you know,
like, “Ah yeah bruh, Jigsaw Rules, he’s
the best,” or if it’s more of a reference
to the fact that Jigsaw holds these games
where the rules have to be followed.
"Why do you need Amanda in the game?"
“To ensure that the rules
are followed.”
It’s also unclear if all of that traffic
was coming from Eleanor, or if Logan was also
responsible for some of it.
Eleanor obviously used it for her weird hobby
of recreating Saw traps, but Logan could have
used it at some point as a resource for his
version of the barn game.
This is Logan’s intellect comes into play,
what makes him more dangerous than some of
Jigsaw’s former disciples.
He’s able to turn this dangerous situation
into his advantage, and here’s how he does
it.
First, he defends Eleanor, even though making
her a suspect could be advantageous for him.
Instead, he uses reverse-psychology.
By protecting Eleanor instead of himself,
he causes the detectives to actually become
more suspicious of her.
It’s not 100% clear if he knew he was being
followed that night as he found Eleanor at
Brewer’s Moon and got her to take him to
her studio, a warehouse filled with her own
recreations of Jigsaw’s now famous traps,
but upon seeing this collection, Nelson realizes
how he can further confuse Hunt, who is tailing
them, by muddying the clarity of the situation.
Eleanor shows him the human blender, which
he recognizes from Kramer’s barn game, but
he plays dumb, telling her that no victims
died in anything like that.
It’s amazing that he was able to keep a
straight face through all of this, perhaps
highlighting his sociopathic tendencies, because
Logan already knew full well that the next
victim of his version of the barn game was
killed in a blender just like this one, so
he plotted to plant the next body in Eleanor’s
studio.
He was especially busy that night though.
He also had time to kidnap Edgar Munsen from
the hospital under the nose of the sleeping
guard, and relocate his body into the tomb
of John Kramer, who was set to be dug up in
order to prove to the public that he was still
dead.
This of course, sent people into a frenzy,
lending more credence to the idea that the
original Jigsaw had returned from beyond the
grave.
Logan never planned on Eleanor being a Jigsaw
fan-girl or Kramer’s body being dug up,
but he was able to stay calm and turn both
of these potential subversions into advantages.
And that’s what makes him such a scary carrier
of the Jigsaw legacy.
He’s able to suppress the rage that used
to get him in trouble after the war, and become
a collected, calculating psychopath, which
is my favorite kind of villain.
The next steps after that were pretty easy,
but would not be without a couple of challenges.
The most obvious was to plant the cut out
jigsaw pieces in Halloran’s freezer.
Remember, the goal isn’t to pin the crime
on Eleanor, she’s just a distraction for
the cops right now.
The real one to take the fall has to be Halloran.
Then, Keith Hunt shows up to arrest Nelson,
thinking he and Bonneville are in cahoots
together and killing the new victims.
Again, he’s able to turn the situation on
it’s head by offering all he knows and essentially
making it look like Halloran is the one trying
to frame him.
He cites the evidence that lines up perfectly
with Halloran being guilty, because he set
everything up that way -- all of the victims
are Halloran’s old cases, and he gave the
order to shoot the remote that Munson was
holding way back… you know, when that happened.
Logan was the one who fired it, but nobody
knew he was even there.
In order to fully clear his name, Nelson suggests
they go back to the medical table and examine
Munson.
When Hunt isn’t looking, he switches the
bullet with one from Halloran’s gun.
This is honestly kind of like the flimsiest
thing in the movie.
I mean the body has already been moved by
the killer this point, so I don’t see why
said killer couldn’t just switch the bullet
out.
I guess Hunt didn’t think about that though,
cause it works.
Hunt takes Nelson home and starts to investigate
Halloran, giving our boy Nelson time to find
Eleanor… well, she finds him, with the news
that she’s discovered the location of the
game.
This is perfect for Logan.
I think at this point he realizes that Halloran
is following him, all he has to do is let
Eleanor lead them to the barn, exactly where
he wants Halloran to be for the final round
of the game.
The one wild card here is Ms. Bonneville,
so he’s gotta find a way to get rid of her
for a little while to give him time to deal
with Halloran.
Once again, Nelson finds a way to turn this
problem into a positive by convincing her
that Halloran is the killer and engaging in
a fight with him.
He tells Eleanor to run, before drugging Halloran
and taking him to the slaughter room.
Now he has one more person believing what
he wants them to believe, someone he probably
wasn’t even counting on being involved.
The final round of the game is no game at
all, it’s a trap, but unlike John Kramer’s
traps, this one is inescapable.
He poses himself inside the room opposite
the detective.
Fabricated audio of John Kramer’s voice
tells them that they can escape death if they
admit the reason they deserve to die.
The whole thing is a setup to get Halloran
to admit to being a dirty cop.
All Nelson has to do is sell it.
So he gives Halloran the chance to choose
who makes their confession first.
Letting him choose is secretly the ultimate
power move, because if he chooses himself,
he’ll probably confess, but if he presses
Logan’s button, he can sell the scenario
even further, because his collar is equipped
with fake lasers and fake blood.
So that’s exactly what he does, he fakes
his death in order to scare Halloran into
making his confession, a confession that Nelson
has a recording of.
A confession of tampering with evidence, taking
bribes, putting away innocent people, letting
the worst criminals walk free and letting
innocent people die.
More than enough to convince most people that
Halloran is the one behind the 2016 killings.
With that evidence, Logan no longer needs
his rival, and after explaining his plan like
a typical villain, he activates the real laser
cutters and executes Detective Halloran.
If anyone knows where I can get one of those
things, I would love to have it to cut my
grapefruit.
So remember how I said there was an issue
with Nelson’s timeline?
Yeah.
There’s an issue with Nelson’s timeline.
Let’s see if we can make some sense of it.
Throughout Jigsaw, characters are constantly
going around saying that Jigsaw can’t be
back, he’s been dead for 10 years.
"Kramer's been dead for 10 years."
"John Kramer's dead, and has been for 10 years."
See.
I told you.
That’s why I’ve been saying that Nelson’s
game takes place in 2016, 10 years after Jigsaw’s
death in 2006.
But at the end of the movie, when Logan does
his evil villain speech, he says that John’s
original game, which he did as a secret test
before all the other games, was 10 years ago.
"Ten years ago in this very barn...
...a game was played."
Well the first game was in 2004, so it can’t
be 10 years since 2004 *and* 10 years since
2006 simultaneously.
Not if both games are on Earth anyway.
The other confusing thing is that Nelson says
Jigsaw helped put him back together his life
after the war.
You may remember he didn’t start to recover
until September 2006, which is actually after
Jigsaw died.
So all of this doesn’t quite add up as neatly
as the seven Saw films.
But there may be a simple explanation.
Well, the simplest explanation is that they
****ed up, but there may be a canon explanation
as well.
There are two options really.
The first is that the game at the barn didn’t
really take place before the bathroom game
in October 2004.
It is stated that Jigsaw’s barn game took
place before all the other games, but what
if it only took place before all the other
games that the public actually knows about?
The earliest known game would be The Nerve
Gas house in Saw II, which happens in October
2005.
That gets us pretty close to 10 years, it
would actually be 11 years in 2016, but it’s
easier to clump the game and the rest of John’s
life together as one event if you do it like
that.
But there is one snag in that theory, which
is that Eleanor’s studio has a replica of
the hacksaw from the bathroom.
You know, the one Gordon used to escape.
Which means the public did find out about
the bathroom at some point.
So the barn game probably took place before
the bathroom game.
There’s also the fact that we see Logan
and John building the reverse bear trap together,
and the reverse bear trap is invented even
earlier than that bathroom game.
We see Amanda tested by it in May of 2004.
That’s why I made this video under the idea
that Jigsaw’s barn game took place shortly
after Logan Nelson switched John’s x-rays
in 2003, and Logan Nelson’s barn game took
place 10 years after Jigsaw’s death in 2006.
This makes the information on Nelson’s file
fit nicely into the series, because it perfectly
explains why Nelson never helped John during
Saw 1-7: he was at war for part of it, and
busy being treated for PTSD for the other
part.
As for Nelson’s line,
"Ten years ago in this very barn... a game was played."
I think it’s possible that he was just generalizing.
He was essentially saying, “this was all
about a decade ago.”
It’s not like he’s been counting year
by year, but he knows it’s been at least
10 years since John Kramer's barn game and
about 10 years since his death.
The last retort that Halloran tries is when
he points out the fact that John Kramer gave
victims a choice to try to win the game.
And Nelson’s response to that is just savage.
Roll that ****.
“You have a choice.
Scream or don’t.”
So Nelson actually ends up committing the
murder himself, unlike Jigsaw, but a lot like
some of the other failed disciples like Amanda
and Hoffman.
Logan Nelson is both a warrior and a tactician.
Once groomed to be the next successor to Jigsaw,
things went horribly wrong when his rehabilitation
was interrupted by service in the military.
The post-traumatic stress that is often a
symptom of mental illness in army veterans
ended up warping and distorting his still
rehabilitating mind into a sociopath and psychopath
-- the likes of which we’ve seen before.
Combine that with his scary physicality and
extremely sharp and fast acting intelligence,
and we could have one of the scariest villains
in the Saw franchise going forward.
At the end of Jigsaw, the only confirmed survivors
among Jigsaw’s successors are Logan Nelson,
who has strayed from the path of John’s
teaching, and Lawrence Gordon, who has protected
his legacy for the last 12 years.
Both are medical masterminds who have also
taken on the arts of mechanical engineering
and deductive reasoning.
One has the advantage of brute force and military
background, and the other has 10 times the
experience being Jigsaw and two unknown apprentices
helping him out.
Hopefully we get to see these two masterminds
battle it out, Jigsaw vs. Jigsaw in a future
movie.
It would be an epic battle that forever changes
the franchise going forward.
So that’s it SO FAR for the history of Logan
Nelson.
Click the video on the left to see more analysis
of your favorite horror characters here on
Horror History.
AND let me know which Saw character I should
cover next.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbell for
notifications and I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.